happening tomorrow the new 7.5 million  dollar ford apache project is making its  debut it's meant to improve pedestrian  and bike safety on the west side of the  road from warm springs to huntington  cove parkway that's right near wigwam  the project includes new bike lanes  sidewalks street lights and travel lanes  for cars county commissioner justin  jones says improvements have been a long  time coming for this area  there were multiple incidences in which  there were cyclists who were hit in that  area  and i think the thing that sort of caps  encapsulated everything is there was a a  hand painted sign on the side of the  road that says please fix this road and  that was  that was the really what put it in  perspective is that someone took the  time to to go  hand paid a sign and put it out there  the next phase will extend these  improvements all the way to blue diamond